how effective do you think cancellation
is at silencing people I saw that sneako
just got another strike on his YouTube
channel Lost His Tick Tock account lost
his Twitter and he seems to not really
see it as a concern Andrew Tate says
that he's got even bigger since he left
do you think that it's cope to say you
get bigger when you're canceled or is it
legit it's huge cope canceling is really
good at getting rid of people he's not
very good at getting rid of ideas though
so they set a type of rhetoric that
creates an echo that other people can
then fall into kind of yeah have you
ever heard of a concept called the
Overton window yes the Overton window is
discovered it's not created so like for
instance Donald Trump didn't necessarily
significantly move the Overton window in
some Direction but he identified there's
a whole group of Voters that felt a
certain way about something and he was
able to tap into that and when you've
got people like Andrew Tate or snico
that are getting really big it's because
there's a hunger for that type of
thought so if you ban him the Banning is
bad for that person you can get rid of
the man but you're probably not going to
get rid of the underlying current of
thought that elevated them to the
position they were in before and that's
going to still be there waiting for
another person to kind of like take the
reins on it